wer von euch weiß was schulfrust ist mal
aufzeigen
okay das sind doch einige ja und es gibt
jetzt ein buch ich weiß ich habe davon
gehört habe vivien sysmark hat es
geschrieben oder cismar dazwischen lagen
genau ausgesprochen wird schon früh
heißt es ich bin birgit hauptschule und
schreibe über das thema und nicht finde
ich glaube wir hatten hier schon früher
verwendete sagen ja
naja ok warum das so ist das wenn man
mit ihm besprechen und wieder eure
fragen und eure fragen also
sehr gut wie immer was muss man machen
irgendwas jetzt lesen genau wie der
infowerk lesen info text lesen genau und
das muss noch und video antwort ist am
besten und
kreative frage
ist ja genau das ist genau er ja es hat
sich rumgesprochen
wir drücken die daumen bis dahin tschüss